Okay. So, I'm going to when as soon as
you hear the balloon set. Okay. Ready?
There we go. Yeah, that
looks so cool. It's interesting how the
rainbow pattern really brings like it
makes
the mo pattern really apparent. Where is
it? Where does it go? Right there.
Oh, you know what would be interesting
to play with,
you know? All right, get back in front
of it. Let's just let's just do some
live recording here.
Are you like taking a Yeah, I'm just
Yeah, I'm just like
Yeah,
that's a really fun video effect where
like you capture one and it rotates out
while you're still dancing side and then
it pops out and you capture that and
just keeps going.
Do it with yourself. Yeah.
Whoa. Yeah.
Nice.
This should just be on a projector at a
concert, you know. Yeah,
that stack would read pretty like Yeah,
it needs to be the right material, but
like
Have you heard from Colin recently?
Like, wow.
[Music]
Yeah.
Sciences.
All right. We need a finale where we can
capture you doing something for exit.
What do we want here? For exit. Yeah.
Spiral towards it. Wait. Here. Ready?
Start out there and spiral run towards
the camera. Right.
All right. Got this. You know what I'm
saying? Like start out there and do wall
plane spiral wrap, but run towards it as
you're spiral wrapping. Oh, well. Or
away from it so it's always clean. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Like here. Ready? Ready?
Yep.
Yeah.
[Music]
What? Okay. Wait. Let me zoom out so we
can get all the way around this
[Music]
thing. Charlie towards it would work
too. That's good. I'm going to stop
the
recording. Well, yeah.